ukraine is under constant attack
this is near cave a smoldering symbol of
russian aggression
the smoke pouring into the sky here
comes from a viennitza airport hit today
by rockets
ukrainian foreign minister claimed the
airfield had been hit by a russian
cruise missile attack
and his country's president repeated his
demand for more support from the west
this is your humanitarian obligation to
protect us to protect people and you can
do it
if you don't do it if you don't provide
us at least with the planes that we
could defend ourselves
then we can come to the only possible
conclusion
you want us to be killed slowly
russia's long military convoy continues
to slowly make its way towards kiev like
a dark cloud approaching the capital
russia has hardly made lightning
progress here but the stage is now set
for a grinding ground war
look at these missiles raining into the
air
sky news has verified and located the
video in pemha 40 miles from central
kiev a military expert has told sky news
that it features two multiple launch
rocket systems the time stamp on the
footage dates it to the 5th of march
the ripples of this terror spread very
far
today the number of refugees fleeing
ukraine went past one and a half million
many more are displaced within the
country itself
today again efforts to evacuate people
from war-torn cities were abandoned due
to russian shelling
where food and medicines are running out
four hundred thousand people are
stranded in a paralyzed ruined city
these children all of them orphans
left zaparica to make the arduous
journey to lev here they joined a bus to
take them across the border to poland
my heart is being torn apart
i'm sorry
i simply lack words and i feel so sorry
for these children they're so young
it's terrifying to stay in zaparizia
when air raid sirens go off and we must
constantly hide in the basement we don't
want to leave ukraine we love it but
unfortunately we must leave
station is a stage for so many scenes of
sadness and separation
this woman had just arrived from kharkiv
her city has been brutally smashed
there were no lights someone has no
water someone has no gas
thank god we could repair things
eve but my parents stayed and
i may never see them again
vladimir putin spoke today to the french
president emmanuel macron but there's
little sign of russia easing its assault
instead there is familiar belligerence
dark warnings against any nation that
might allow ukrainian warplanes to use
its airfields
draw attention to the fact that using
the airfield network of those countries
to harbor ukrainian combat aviation with
subsequent use against russian armed
forces may be evaluated as said
countries engaging in the military
conflict
and ranged against that is ukraine's
resolve there were protests today in
places seized by russian troops
this one is
in the carson region the crowd shout
henichesk is ukraine russians go home
but they won't they are here and
fighting the ukrainian news agency
interface reports that russian troops
opened fire at this separate protest
wounding five people this is a brutal
conflict and it's not going to end soon
adam parsons sky news lev western
ukraine